Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed, Noble and Fully Self-Enlightened One.
Homage au Bouddha, au saint, au béni ou parfaitement illuminé par lui-même.
J'ai donc pensé cette soirée parler de la roue de l'origination dépendante et cela me permet aussi de répéter, d'une certaine manière, tout ce qui
Je pense que vous parlez ce soir de la production conditionnée, ce qui va me permettre d'insérer dans cet enseignement tout ce qui a été dit les jours précédents et également au cours des entretiens.
juste pour que vous puissiez comprendre que l'enseignement que j'ai donné vient d'un certain format.
Donc, j'ai lu, je veux dire, on ne sait pas combien c'est vrai de l'étude des académiques,
rien comme la psychologie dont le Bouddha a parlé avait déjà apparu dans la littérature indienne mais maintenant je pense que vous trouverez les principales parties de cela
Mais vous trouverez probablement actuellement dans la philosophie hindoue une grande partie de cet enseignement.
Et j'ai pu constater cela lorsque j'ai lu Ramana Maharshi, un très célèbre gourou indien.
Souvenez-vous que dès qu'on parle de l'enseignement du Bouddha, il ne s'agit jamais
de la souffrance, de l'aliénation, de l'impression de malaise.
Autrement dit, il s'agit de toutes les formes de misère humaine.
et de la cessation de cette misère.
Donc, souvenez-vous que dans l'enseignement Theravada, il ne sera jamais question que de souffrance, souffrance, dukkha, dukkha.
Mais ce n'est que la première noble vérité.
La première noble vérité annonce que dukkha est une réalité.
Personne ne peut la nier.
Et donc ceci, cette souffrance, c'est la maladie, si on veut reprendre la formulation ancienne du temps des Bouddhas.
Le prognostic est magnifique.
Le prognostic, c'est qu'il y a une fin possible à la souffrance.
La deuxième noble vérité annonce la cause de la souffrance.
La cause de Dukkha, c'est le désir.
Ce désir qui provient bien sûr de l'illusion d'un moi réel.
La quatrième noble vérité c'est la noble vérité du chemin qui mène à la cessation de la souffrance.
Et donc lorsqu'il s'agit de la suite psychologique de la souffrance, ce qui est en fait la deuxième noble vérité,
Il s'agit en réalité de la chaîne des origines interdépendantes.
Donc, nous allons tout d'abord passer en revue les douze maillons de cette chaîne et ensuite nous allons nous attarder un peu sur certains aspects.
Le premier est ce mot Avijja.
Avijja est traduit plutôt mal comme ignorance.
Mais c'est en fait
le premier maillon c'est ce que l'on appelle en palais avidja et on traduit avidja assez maladroitement par le mot ignorance il vaudrait mieux parler de ne pas savoir parce que le terme ignorance implique une idée de culpabilité, de stupidité
Mais ce n'est pas le cas, c'est simplement le fait de ne pas savoir.
Et à cause que nous ne savons pas, nous commençons à créer l'illusion d'un moi.
et ce moi va alors faire naître toutes les conditionnements dont nous faisons l'expérience en cours de méditation et donc ces conditionnements sont appelés les sankharas, ce qui est confectionné
Et donc, ces deux premiers maillons, donc Avijja et Sankara, sont présents de façon invisible tout au long de notre vie de tous les jours.
Oui, j'entends bien.
Excusez-moi, sont sous-jacents à notre vie de tous les jours.
OK.
Alors, nous arrivons à...
les liens de la Conscience, vijnana, Consciousness.
Ensuite, il y a le corps et l'esprit.
Ensuite, il y a le corps et l'esprit, les six sens.
Donc le sixth sense est le corps ou le cerveau, on pourrait dire.
Le sixième sens est l'esprit lui-même.
Le sixième sens, c'est l'endroit où se rejoignent le cerveau et l'esprit.
c'est la perception, c'est en fait l'endroit où l'on reconnaît les objets ensuite il y a passa, le contact, le moment où l'objet entre en contact avec l'esprit
Du contact viennent les sensations, et les sensations nous les reconnaissons immédiatement comme étant soit agréables, soit désagréables, soit neutres.
Vient ensuite la réaction, et cette réaction c'est tanha.
Donc cette réaction, c'est ne pas vouloir ce qui est désagréable, c'est vouloir ce qui est agréable et c'est ignorer ce qui est neutre.
Ensuite, il y a l'identification avec cela, l'appréciation de cela comme moi.
Ensuite vient l'identification à ces choses comme étant moi.
Et dès qu'il y a je veux ou je ne veux pas, la volonté va entrer en action.
Cette volonté qui entre en action, c'est le karma.
une action verbale, physique ou vocale et cette action crée le conditionnement que nous appelons le devenir le devenir
Et dès que nous sommes dans le devenir, il y aura le début du devenir, le prolongement du devenir et la fin du devenir.
le début c'est la naissance, dans le cadre d'une vie humaine par exemple, la continuation, le prolongement, c'est la vieillesse, et la fin c'est la mort.
Et dans un laps de temps plus court,
Le début, c'est la décision de manger quelque chose.
Le prolongement, c'est le fait de manger cette chose.
Et la fin, c'est la tristesse d'avoir terminé.
Pas quelque chose, cream cake.
Du gâteau, cream cake.
À la crème.
À la gâteau ou à la crème.
So, there's your twelve links, yes?
Et donc nous pouvons commencer par le maillon central, là où nous commençons avec le désir.
il y a donc le contact le contact peut être de six sortes selon le sens qu'il y a le contact le contact peut être intérieur si c'est une émotion ou une pensée
Donc, à ce moment-là, il s'agirait d'un contact qui vient par l'une des six portes sensorielles de l'esprit.
Dès que quelque chose entre en contact par l'une des portes sensorielles avec la conscience, le contact a lieu.
Il faut donc que ces trois choses soient présentes pour que nous puissions expérimenter.
L'objet, la base sensorielle et la conscience.
Si par exemple vous avez perdu la vue, l'œil, les yeux, vous avez perdu du même coup ce canal par lequel un contact pourrait s'établir.
Et si vous vous trouvez dans une pièce où il fait son, où il n'y a pas de lumière, vous avez également perdu la possibilité d'avoir un contact.
Et vous ne verrez rien non plus si vous êtes endormi et que donc l'élément conscience fait défaut.
La conscience est encore là puisque si vous avez froid vous allez vous couvrir.
Et lorsque vous rêvez, il y a une conscience visuelle.
Et ensuite vient la reconnaissance, la perception de cette sensation comme étant agréable, désagréable ou neutre.
Le Bouddha nous explique que cette séquence à douze maillons, ces douze maillons se succèdent chez tous les êtres vivants quels qu'ils soient, du plus grand au plus petit, même les insectes.
Lorsque nous sommes en méditation et que nous observons le souffle, les sensations qui se manifestent sont neutres.
Lorsque vous avez une douleur dans le genou, vous la percevez comme douloureuse.
Et lorsque vous ressentez le calme dans le corps, c'est une sensation que vous reconnaissez comme étant agréable.
Mais cette reconnaissance des sensations comme étant agréable, désagréable ou neutre, c'est en fait une construction de l'esprit.
C'est l'esprit qui reconnaît.
Cela n'appartient pas au corps lui-même.
C'est pourquoi j'ai demandé aux méditants, au moment de l'entretien,
D'essayer d'entrer, d'être en contact, d'observer très attentivement la sensation émotionnelle qu'il ressentait éventuellement, de façon à arriver au contact à l'état pur.
Par exemple, lorsque nous avons une douleur au genou, c'est l'esprit qui interprète ces sensations comme étant douloureuses.
Mais si vous observez très attentivement cette sensation à l'état pur, vous ne ressentirez probablement que de la brûlure ou de la chaleur.
Et si nous sommes capables d'observer avec cette qualité d'attention, le concept de douleur va s'estomper.
Mais ceci, bien sûr, ne doit pas nécessairement être fait dans la vie de tous les jours.
Il s'agit ici, dans ce contexte-ci, de faire une investigation très approfondie de la réalité pour voir comment les choses se passent.
Dans la vie de tous les jours, si votre corps fait mal, c'est que probablement vous devez voir un médecin.
Mais même s'il s'agit d'une maladie réelle que vous auriez, vous pouvez encore toujours l'observer comme une sensation à l'état pur Et si vous êtes capable de le faire, ça ne fera pas si mal
parce que lorsque l'on perçoit quelque chose comme, disons, douloureux il y a cette réaction immédiate de ne pas en vouloir maintenant jusqu'au point de vedanā, de ressenti il n'y a encore aucune réaction de l'esprit
Jusqu'au moment où Vedana, la sensation, va se manifester, il n'y a pas encore de réaction de l'esprit.
Il n'y a pas encore de construction d'un soi.
Le Bouddha l'a expliqué et l'a expérimenté jusqu'à la sensation.
Il était encore un être humain.
Mais donc l'illumination ne va pas nous faire perdre notre capacité à percevoir les choses.
vous devenez beaucoup plus attentif ou conscient de cette base sensuelle il y a une nettoyage des portes de la perception il y a une nettoyage, une nettoyage des portes de la perception
Il y aura un nettoyage des portes par lesquelles on perçoit les objets.
Dans le langage traditionnel, on parle des portes, des portes sensorielles.
Si vous avez fait des retraites de longue durée vous serez peut-être étonné de voir comme le ciel est bleu et comme l'herbe est verte.
C'est tout simplement parce qu'à ce moment-là les conditionnements ont disparu et il y a une perception directe de la réalité.
et c'est la même chose avec la nourriture les aliments auront beaucoup plus de goût une retraite, une des méditantes est venue me trouver et m'a remercié chaleureusement parce que c'était la première fois que les carottes avaient un goût pour elle
Et maintenant, il y a cette réaction de désirer la chose, ne la pas désirer et l'ignorer.
Pendant la méditation, nous devons devenir conscients de cette réaction.
Si nous sommes capables d'être conscients de cette réaction, la séquence va s'interrompre à ce niveau.
Le désir de vouloir, de ne pas vouloir ou d'ignorer va simplement mourir.
le désir de posséder, le désir de ne pas posséder ou le désir d'ignorer va s'estomper, va disparaître.
Tout ceci s'enracine dans l'ignorance et dans la croyance en l'existence réelle du je.
Le moment après cela est appelé Upadana, ou « grasping », et c'est le point où le « self » dit « je veux », « je ne veux pas ».
L'égo désire posséder, je désire posséder.
Identification.
Donc, dans notre langue, nous allons dire
Dans notre langage, nous dirions « je désire le gâteau à la crème ».
Mais du point de vue psychologique, ce serait plutôt « le gâteau à la crème veut je ».
Ces choses se passent, bien sûr, en millisecondes.
Mais tout ceci se passe extrêmement rapidement, en dixièmes et millième de seconde.
Et dès le moment où cette identification a eu lieu, donc le « je » qui veut l'objet, il devient pratiquement impossible d'empêcher l'action.
La volonté d'assombrir l'objectif.
Il devient pratiquement impossible d'éviter que la volonté ne devienne active.
Comment renforcer ?
Non, empowering, c'est mettre de la... Mettre de la force.
Comment tu dis ?
Oui, c'est ça.
C'est rendre puissant, si tu veux, rendre actif.
Activer, je dirais.
Pas renforcer, non, rendre actif, je dirais.
Rendre actif, ça va.
Rendre actif le désir.
Oui, c'est ça, activer, je crois que c'est ça.
activez le désir il doit y avoir un mot en français oui, bien donc vous pouvez votre concentration et votre énergie doivent être absolument sur ce point pour arrêter la volonté pour arrêter la volonté d'empowerer et c'est virtuellement impossible dans la vie quotidienne c'est je pense absolument impossible
Donc, même si on y met toute son énergie, qu'on s'efforce d'éviter cela, c'est pratiquement impossible dans la vie de tous les jours.
Nous devons donc nous entraîner à être attentifs et conscients du moment où l'on va commencer à désirer ou ne pas désirer.
À ce moment-là, nous contrôlons notre sagesse.
À ce moment-là, la sagesse contrôle le processus.
ceci veut dire que l'ego ne va pas se mettre à vivre parce qu'il y a la discrimination par la sagesse à ce point nous pouvons nous demander est-ce que ce désir est wholesome ou non wholesome ?
et à ce point nous pouvons alors nous poser la question de savoir si ce désir est positif ou négatif est-il bénéfique ou pas bénéfique est-il vertueux ou pervers ?
Parce que, souvenez-vous que nos actions immorales, négatives, sont la mesure de notre égo.
Et l'expression de notre égo.
Dès qu'il y a avidité, colère, c'est l'expression de l'égo.
Donc, si nous voyons que notre réaction à avoir avec de la colère, de la peur ou de l'avidité, nous savons que c'est négatif.
Donc, vous dites, vous attendez, juste comme dans la méditation, c'est la vie quotidienne, vous attendez jusqu'à ce que le désir fasse disparaître.
À ce moment-là, vous devez vous comporter comme en méditation, vous attendez simplement que ce désir s'estompe.
Et vous aurez gagné sur deux tableaux, vous aurez réussi à éviter de tomber dans la tentation, vous aurez également réussi à atténuer la disposition à cette habitude.
Ceci est très important à comprendre.
Donc il faut comprendre qu'il ne s'agit pas uniquement de s'abstenir de quelque chose de nuisible, mais qu'il s'agit également
de diminuer, d'atténuer les tendances à cette chose nous-mêmes ce que nous essayons de faire, c'est donc nous donner le temps ou donner le temps à nos habitudes négatives de s'estomper
Mais il faut également comprendre que ce processus de purification ne peut se faire que consciemment
Parce que tant que ces choses resteront à moitié conscientes dans le subconscient, pourrait-on dire, elles restent des forces actives.
Maintenant, j'ai été emprunté comme catholique, et je sais que beaucoup d'entre vous l'étaient aussi, et nous avions trois... trois différents domaines à aller.
Nous pouvions aller à la mort, au ciel, ou à la purgatoire.
j'ai été élevé dans la religion catholique comme sans doute beaucoup d'entre vous et nous n'avions que trois possibilités le paradis, l'enfer ou le purgatoire l'enfer du point de vue psychologique c'est l'endroit où il n'y a plus moyen de s'échapper il n'y a pas d'échappatoire possible de l'enfer désespoir, panique
Oui, une dépression profonde.
Ce sont des états que les êtres humains entrent, où ils ne voient pas d'escapement.
C'est l'enfer.
Oui.
Maintenant, vous pouvez souffrir autant, mais au moins vous pouvez voir qu'il y a un escapement.
C'est la purgatoire.
La plupart de notre méditation, 99,9 % est purgatoire.
Parce que
Il n'est pas possible d'atteindre le paradis sans passer par le purgatoire.
Il faut que le processus de purification puisse se faire.
et le permettre de passer, alors plus rapidement nous serons hors de ce état de purgatoire.
Mais ici, il y a aussi l'insight.
Mais en réalité, si vous êtes donc capable de maintenir votre attention très fermement sur la douleur et la souffrance qu'elle provoque, en réalité vous ne souffrez pas.
le désir est-ce que c'est ça ?
Vous ne souffrez pas, même si cette sensation est douloureuse.
Donc, je vous ai parlé les jours précédents du cône et de sa base circulaire.
À la base, il y a le désir, la sensation agréable, le désir qu'il n'en finisse pas de tourner et de retourner.
Il y a également la sensation désagréable et le désir de ne pas l'avoir, de ne pas l'expérimenter.
Tout ceci tourne.
à l'infini, mais en tant que méditant vipassana, vous avez la possibilité de vous retrouver au sommet du cône et de tout observer.
Si vous êtes capable de vous maintenir là, vous ne souffrez pas.
Et donc si par un moment nous perdons ce statut de témoin objectif autrement dit que nous tombons du sommet du cône de nouveau dans le cercle qui se trouve en dessous nous allons de nouveau être pris dans cette espèce de répétition à l'infini du désir
Nous renforçons le conditionnement.
C'est très important.
Même quand nous avons agi d'une manière habituelle,
Même si quelque chose se produit par habitude, nous renforçons cette habitude.
C'est encore pire, bien sûr, si vous décidez consciemment de renforcer cette habitude, cette mauvaise habitude.
Par exemple, vous pouvez avoir l'habitude de manger des gâteaux à la crème.
Et vous les avez tous autour de vous, dans votre maison.
Et quand vous passez un bol, même sans le savoir, vous le prenez et vous le mangez.
Et dès que vous passez à côté d'une étagère où il y a ce gâteau, sans savoir, inconsciemment, vous prenez un morceau.
Ceci s'est fait par habitude.
Mais le résultat est là, vous renforcez cette habitude.
Mais si vous vous arrêtez et que vous décidez délibérément de manger d'un seul coup 20 gâteaux, vous renforcez très puissamment cette habitude.
Pour être plus réaliste, il y a alors le problème du sommeil.
Seek refuge in the bed.
Le fait de faire du sommeil, son refuge.
Parfois, si vous êtes allongé sur votre lit, vous tombez endormi sans même réaliser que peut-être ce n'est pas utile.
Et on le ressent dans la méditation comme la douleur et la lethargie.
Et ceci va avoir pour conséquence que le besoin de sommeil va se renforcer, et lorsque vous irez vous asseoir pour méditer, vous serez très vite pris par la somnolence.
Si, par exemple, vous êtes assis dans un tram ou dans un bus, il est possible que vous tombiez facilement endormi.
Mais si vous vous dites à vous-même « Oh, je suis vraiment fatigué, je vais juste aller dormir maintenant » et vous allez dormir.
Donc, c'est un acte de volonté.
Et cela développe vraiment ce habit.
Donc, nous devons être très prudents
donc nous devons devenir très habiles dans l'art d'observer le désir de façon précise et de voir si ce désir est positif ou non s'il est positif nous pouvons le réaliser mais s'il ne l'est pas nous devons nous abstenir même dans la vie quotidienne vous voyez
Même dans la vie quotidienne.
Vous ne pouvez pas arrêter ce travail.
Vous ne pouvez pas aller en vacances.
Une fois que vous arrêtez, ça devient pire.
Une fois que vous comprenez ce dont nous parlons, c'est impossible de s'arrêter.
Parce que vous savez que si vous arrêtez, vous vous déplacez vers la mort.
Une fois que vous aurez compris ceci, il devient impossible pour vous d'interrompre votre effort parce que vous comprenez que si vous l'interrompez une seule fois, vous vous dirigez tout droit vers l'enfer.
Nous avons parlé jusqu'à présent de la façon dont nous créons notre propre souffrance.
mais nous allons également
développer le désir qui s'enracine dans la sagesse et de cette façon nous allons développer des états d'esprit positifs, identifiés ?
oui, oui, donc nous utilisons la même technique pour développer l'amour, la compassion, la joie sympathique donc il n'y a rien de mal avec la technique mais avec l'attitude
Donc ce n'est pas la technique qui est importante, c'est l'attitude.
Si notre attitude s'enracine dans des états d'esprit négatifs comme la colère, l'avidité, etc., cela va produire des états d'esprit négatifs.
Mais si notre attitude s'enracine plutôt dans des choses positives comme la compassion, l'amour universel, la joie sympathique, nous allons tout doucement construire des états, introduire des états d'esprit positifs.
C'est pour ça que nous pratiquons Metta.
C'est un désir que nous exprimons, « Puissais-je être heureux ?
» « Puissiez-vous être heureux ?
»
Et ceci sera renforcé par le fait de parler de façon agréable et de pratiquer par exemple la générosité.
dès que le Bouddha fut illuminé sa première pensée fut pour les autres à qui puis-je venir en aide ?
il a dit
Tout ce qu'un maître, tout ce qu'un professeur peut faire pour aider ses élèves, je l'ai fait pour vous.
Par compassion.
Tout ce qu'un professeur peut faire par compassion pour ses élèves, je l'ai fait pour vous.
En palais, le mot veut dire se diriger vers la personne.
Donc, nous ne sommes pas...
La origination de la roue de la dépendance nous dit seulement comment nous créons la souffrance.
Donc cette roue de la production conditionnée nous enseigne tout simplement comment nous sommes conditionnés.
Donc nous avons décrit la partie centrale de la chaîne, le domaine de la méditation.
Donc maintenant,
C'est cette ignorance, ce non-savoir.
Et ce non-savoir, sa première création, est moi.
Je pense que vous avez tous expérimenté
Je pense que vous avez tous dû déjà expérimenter le fait de vous endormir dans un endroit que vous ne connaissiez pas, comme un hôtel par exemple, et de vous réveiller le lendemain matin en vous demandant où vous étiez.
Avez-vous ressenti la panique ?
Et puis, soudainement, oh, c'est moi, je suis là.
Donc, la première chose, c'est ce « je ».
Maintenant, ce « je » doit croire qu'il peut être heureux dans ce monde.
Parce que c'est le seul monde que le « je » connaît.
Et lorsque quelque chose va se produire qui rend ce « je » heureux, il en voudra plus.
Le « je » se dit, si je pouvais avoir cette chose tout le temps, je serais tout le temps heureux.
Et ça, c'est l'attachement.
Et avec l'attachement, apparaît le désir d'avoir plus.
Lorsque vous êtes
Vous êtes pris dans un processus d'enrichissement, vous n'aurez jamais assez.
Parce que vous savez qu'un peu plus d'argent va vous rendre un peu plus heureux.
D'autre part, tout ce qui rend ce « je » malheureux doit être annihilé.
Ça c'est l'aversion, ne pas vouloir.
Et si cette sensation est trop forte, il n'y a plus que la fuite.
Donc d'un côté il y a l'attachement, le désir de rendre cette chose plus grande,
et de l'autre côté c'est essayer de détruire, de s'en sortir de tout ce qui me cause des problèmes donc c'est là votre psychologie fondamentale qui est à la base de tout, de toutes les émotions négatives et des pensées que nous avons créées
Et ceci, c'est vraiment à cet endroit précis que s'enracinent toutes les pensées et les états d'esprit négatifs.
Les états négatifs.
ces deux choses, de vouloir et de ne pas vouloir, nous détruisons lentement le self.
Donc maintenant, qu'est-ce que c'est que ce self ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Nous découvrons que c'est juste un concept.
Mais en quoi consiste réellement ce « je », cet ego ?
Et nous allons voir qu'il ne s'agit que d'un concept.
Toute la journée, nous fonctionnons avec des concepts.
Même lorsque vous voyez une voiture, il s'agit d'un concept.
C'est un concept concret, parce que vous pouvez le toucher et le ressentir, etc., etc.
mais vous savez que ça peut être coupé en morceaux et que ça n'existe pas comme un voiture si vous prenez un concept, même un grand concept comme la démocratie et la justice vous verrez que c'est fait de petites choses
et si vous prenez de grands concepts comme la démocratie et que vous la décomposez en ces parties vous verrez qu'il ne s'agit jamais que de petites parties parfois ces concepts planent à un niveau idéaliste et ils n'ont pas en contact avec la réalité alors nous savons par exemple que même si la démocratie est probablement le meilleur système que nous avons pour le gouvernement ce n'est pas parfait
Nous savons, par exemple, que même si la démocratie est considérée comme la meilleure forme de gouvernement que nous puissions avoir, ce n'est pas parfait.
Mais dans notre esprit, la démocratie, c'est parfait.
Gouverné par les gens, pour les gens, à travers les gens.
Et lorsque le Bouddha décrit la façon de s'extraire de la souffrance il ne va pas repasser en revue tous ces maillons à l'envers
il commence par l'avidya, avec l'ignorance et il dit que quand l'ignorance disparaît tout le reste va disparaître également donc cette ignorance, ce non-souci, non culpable, non culpable, juste non-souci
donc cette ignorance, ce fait de ne pas savoir qui a créé inévitablement la notion que c'est cet être humain qui a créé l'idée que ceci est un être humain une fois qu'il perçoit que cela n'est pas vrai toute la roue s'est écrasée
Lorsque donc il perçoit que tout ceci est faux, toute la chaîne va se disloquer.
Mais maintenant, à cause de toutes les choses horribles que nous avons faites au cours de notre vie, nous nous sentons peut-être coupables, honteux,
Tout cela va complètement disparaître lorsque l'ego disparaît.
Si ces choses devaient rester lorsque l'ignorance a disparu, cela voudrait dire que nous sommes fondamentalement mauvais.
Mais toutes ces choses négatives que nous avons faites s'enracinent dans une vision erronée de la réalité.
Et nous découvrons alors qu'en fait nous avons toujours été innocents.
Nous commençons d'un état de ne pas connaître, et au cours du processus de l'awakening, nous arrivons à un état de connaissance, de sagesse.
Et nous devons passer au cours du processus de l'illusion, et ensuite de la délusion.
Nous devons passer à travers le processus de l'ignorance, du non-savoir, et décomposer cette ignorance.
Pourquoi cela doit-il se faire ?
Le Bouddha n'a rien dit.
Mais c'est ce que nous expérimentons tous.
Au niveau du cœur,
Et du point de vue du cœur, nous partons donc de l'innocence, nous passons à travers tout ce processus de décomposition et de purification et nous arrivons à la pureté.
nous commençons donc par un état d'innocence et de non-savoir on fait une erreur cette erreur va nous envoyer aux enfers
Nous nous réveillons et nous nous demandons comment on va faire pour sortir de l'enfer.
Et nous trouvons Vipassana.
Par Vipassana, nous allons passer par le purgatoire, le processus de purification.
Et nous arrivons à la wisdom et la pureté du cœur.
C'est ce que nous allons traverser.
C'est la vie.